hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we're going to be discussing ancient
magic a phenomenon that has recently
become popularized through the
best-selling Harry Potter game Hogwarts
Legacy a magic this powerful can do
great harm in the wrong hands it must be
wielded by select few but what exactly
is ancient magic how does it differ from
regular magic where does it pop up in
the Harry Potter story and what do we
know of its history all of these
questions and more will be answered in
today's video so sit back relax and
enjoy as we peel back the layers of the
enigmatic phenomenon known as ancient
magic what is it in the World of Harry
Potter ancient magic refers to powerful
complex spells and rituals that have
been passed down to Wizarding history
for thousands of years these magical
practices are often shrouded in mystery
and Legend and many of them are
considered dangerous or forbidden
perhaps the most enigmatic component of
ancient magic however is that its
prevalence has seemingly diminished over
time with very little ancient magic
still existing in the current ERA by the
19th century ancient magic had become an
obscure and Powerful form of magic that
was steeped in mystery a rarity that had
seemingly all but vanished from The
Wizarding World those who had the
capability to perceive and manipulate it
were considered to have a unique and
exceptional ability and even Hogwarts
professors had a limited understanding
of it the Harry Potter lexicon described
it as follows ancient magic is Magic
which happens independently of efforts
by Wizards an effect which is triggered
by events and Powers endemic to the
nature of reality it is extremely old
and mysterious and a wand is not
necessary for it to work it is part of
the magicalness of the Universe on the
whole ancient Magic in Harry Potter
represents the rich history and
complexity of The Wizarding World adding
a layer of mystery and Intrigue to an
already enigmatic Universe how is it
different from Regular Magic who can use
it ancient magic is different from
Modern Magic in several ways first it
requires a deeper understanding of the
nature of magic itself and often
involves more complex incantations wand
movements and other magical gestures
second ancient magic is often tied to
ancient artifacts or locations and
requires a certain level of knowledge or
expertise to access it's also worth
noting that ancient magic appeared in
traces or Whispers to those with the
ability to harness it over the course of
history few individuals have truly
possessed the ability to wield ancient
magic and its Mastery is widely
appreciated as a sign of a particularly
powerful witch or wizard what's even
more interesting about ancient Magic is
that all known practitioners of ancient
magic discover that they were capable of
wielding it upon starting their
education at Hogwarts in their fifth
year this suggests that there may be a
link between using ancient magic and
being a late bloomer the Hogwarts Castle
itself is also said to have been built
by ancient magic which makes it a
stronghold of Swords this could be part
of a link between ancient magic and
Hogwarts students being able to take
advantage of it
history though the true origins of
ancient magic are still unclear I do
have a plethora of theories that touch
on where it may have originated
hopefully one of them hits the nail on
the head but you guys will be the judge
of that number one my first theory is
that ancient magic has always existed
and is linked to the natural world and
the forces of the universe in this way
the power of ancient magic is rooted in
the same fundamental forces that govern
the physical world such as gravity
electromagnetism the strong force and
the weak Force this Theory suggests that
ancient magic is a kind of cosmic energy
and or universal language that can be
harnessed and directed by a select group
of witches and wizards two my second
theory is that ancient magic is tied to
the spirits and creatures of the
Wizarding World in this instance ancient
magical practices would have been
developed in close collaboration with
the magical creatures and beings that
populate the Wizarding World such as
dragons unicorns and centaurs this
Theory takes on a much narrower scope
than the last and instead suggests that
ancient magic originates from a
microcosm of The Wizarding World my
third theory is that ancient magic is
somehow tied to the spirits of the Dead
the afterlife is a common theme in Harry
Potter and we know that the border
between life and death is a lot more
complex in The Wizarding World with
various stages of being existing in
between this Theory suggests that
skilled practitioners of ancient magic
are able to unknowingly communicate with
and even command the spirits of deceased
witches and wizards drawing on their
knowledge and Power
my fourth theory is that ancient magic
is tied to the earliest days of The
Wizarding World when magic was still new
and Untamed according to this Theory the
first Wizards and witches may have
discovered powerful magical practices
through trial and error and these
practices were then passed down through
the generations as ancient magic this
Theory suggests that perhaps ancient
magic stems from some form of cultural
inheritance passed down through the
generations as a way of preserving the
history and traditions of The Wizarding
World at the end of the day these are
just theories and the origins of ancient
magic remain unclear but at least I'm
living up to my channel name examples of
ancient magic in Harry Potter to some
the concept of ancient magic may have
appeared to have originated entirely
from hoku's Legacy however the ultra
perceptive will know that ancient magic
has already been discussed in the Harry
Potter story many many years before the
release of Hogwarts Legacy it's all also
put on our radar right near the
beginning of the very first book when
Voldemort attempts to kill baby Harry to
quote Dumbledore you would be protected
by an ancient magic of which he knows
which he despises and which he has
always therefore underestimated to his
cost I am speaking of course of the fact
that your mother died to save you she
gave you a lingering protection he never
expected a protection that flows in your
veins to this day in this passage
Dumbledore was referring to sacrificial
protection the loving enchantment that
Lily Potter placed on Harry in order to
save him from Voldemort's killing curse
she sacrificed herself to protect her
son and this act of selflessness created
a powerful magical Shield that protected
Harry from harm this Shield continued to
protect Harry throughout his life and
was a major factor in his eventual
victory over Voldemort in Harry Potter
The Power of Love is often portrayed as
a powerful and mysterious Force but what
you may have never realized is that it's
actually a form of ancient magic this is
reinforced by the fact that in many ways
The Power of Love operates on a level
that is beyond the purely physical or
material it Taps into something deeper
and more fundamental than simple spells
or potions the same ancient magic love
awakened is alt ser and her husband
during Gormley gaunt's attack on
ilvermorny school ancient magic is also
responsible for the inherent magic
resistance in the skin of dragons and
Giants but these are just a few tangible
examples of ancient magic in reality
it's likely that ancient magic is at
least somewhat woven into the very
structure of the Wizarding World As for
the face of ancient magic well it
somewhat touched on in Hogwarts Legacy
and I don't want to spoil anything
perhaps I'll make a revised video with a
more complete answer once everyone's had
a chance to play beat the game and
that's it for this video I hope hope you
learned something about the origins of
ancient magic if you have any more
questions related to this topic or
others then please leave a comment down
below until next time remember it does
not do to dwell on dreams and forget to
live
foreign